American sniper is directed by the one
and only Clint Eastwood and stars
Bradley Cooper that was stupid
it's a true story of Chris Kyle a sniper
who was on record as the deadly sniper
ever with the most confirmed kills
it takes us through the various tours
that he went on as well as his family
life with his wife played by Sienna
Miller that was very excited for this
movie he went through a lot of different
hands at one point David O'Russell was
considering directing this movie and
then Steven Spielberg was going to
direct it and now it's being directed by
Clint Eastwood who for quite some time
has been one of the best directors ever
however he's kind of in the middle of an
it streak Jersey Boys I thought was
really bad Jay Edgar was very thick and
this movie is good is it great I don't
think it is because there's a lot of
different things that this movie doesn't
explore that would have made it so much
better the positives first Bradley
Cooper is amazing in this movie he gives
an excellent subdued and nuanced
performance he is terrific the
cinematography looks very good the
action sequences are fairly well handled
there is definitely some suspense and
some heart-pounding scenes in the film
however Eastwood takes a very
black-and-white approach to this movie
despite the fact that the subject matter
is kind of a gray area there's a lot of
controversy surrounding this movie and
the fact that a lot of people don't
really think that this man should be
idolized because of some of the things
he has said in his own biography this
movie doesn't explore any of that it
basically paints him as a perfect war
hero who rescued a lot of people's lives
it doesn't really go into the more deep
and darker aspects of what
post-traumatic stress syndrome can do to
someone and how that can truly affect
him there are scenes that definitely
show that he is a wounded man but the
film doesn't explore any of the emotions
that it really could and it kind of just
becomes a procedural look at his tours
that he went on and you don't really
learn much of anything about any of the
other characters and Chris Kyle played
by Cooper is by far the only interesting
character in the movie and everyone else
just kind of sinks to be like this side
character presence now I don't really
have an opinion on this subject because
I'm neutral
I don't like having
pending on things that I wasn't there
for I'm just saying that the film could
have explored considerably more
emotional elements it could have gone
deeper into the man's psyche it could
have explored so much more at an
emotional level and it would have been
such a more interesting film that's what
I'm saying I'm not saying that the
actual person shouldn't receive some
praise for his heroic acts hell no I'm
not saying that what I'm saying is the
film itself really could have gone
deeper the action sequence is truly our
heart pounding and Cooper does terrific
work I just don't really think that
American sniper is a film that really
deserves a Best Picture nomination I
don't really think that's where the best
pictures of the year I think that it is
a fine film but that it doesn't explore
any of the emotional places that it
could have gone and for that reason I'm
going to give American sniper a C+ I
don't think it is nearly as good as it
could have been I think there are
terrific performances and some very good
action sequences but it just comes off
as a procedural drama that looks at
certain times in his life and it doesn't
really reflect on the true depths of
emotion that it could have gotten into
guys what are your thoughts on American
sniper I don't think it's like a bad
film don't get me wrong I just think it
could have been much more what are your
thoughts on the film what are your
thoughts on the story let me know below
and also I'm really looking forward to
sharing with you guys my first ever
episode of retro rewind it's going to be
entirely about Toonami the programming
block that popularized anime in the 90s
I now have three awesome celebrity
guests that are going to take part in it
who have all been involved with tsunami
in some way shape or form over the years
it was at first it was just one and now
three people are going to be helping me
with this video I can't wait to share
with you guys I've been working super
hard on it it's a brand new segment and
I cannot wait to share this segment with
you guys and I hope you enjoy it as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck man eyes